we want to enjoy the experiences that
we're having we want to have each other
there to experience it together like I
think it's all about playing with the
ones that you love still liking them and
loving them at the same time Stephen
twitch boss's wife Allison holker has
been granted half of his artist's
earnings after the dancer died without a
will according to documents obtained by
E.T a judge from the Superior Court of
California in LA county signed off on
Allison's request for the spousal
property petition she filed earlier this
year California law says that surviving
spouses are entitled to half of their
spouse's joint estate but the surviving
spouse still has to file the petition to
prove they are the spouse of the
deceased I have the sweetest husband in
the entire world the donks confirmed
Allison's identity as twitch's surviving
spouse and granted her property passing
rights noting that no administration of
it is necessary the documents state that
the former Ellen Degeneres Show Producer
died without a will and determined that
his wife now possesses half of his
interest earnings from his Goldman Sachs
investment account as well as royalties
from cast and crew Production Services
Disney worldwide Services Inc gep Talent
services and sag-aftra I'm so grateful
that I've had SEMA Parma life Allison
will also receive half of her late
husband's interest in 100 of all shares
of Stephen boss Productions Inc
twitch died by suicide in December
Stephen twitch lit up every room and he
was so positive I think anyone who's
ever met twitch will say that he is the
nicest most caring most you know present
person and and really wants to make
everyone feel better in February Allison
addressed fans in her first video
message following his death it has been
very challenging and emotional
but you guys have brought
so much hope and inspiration to us by
sharing stories and memories and moments
and different ways that Stephen impacted
your life Allison's emotional post came
shortly after 500 friends and family
members gathered in La for his
celebration of life Ellen DeGeneres
Portia de Rossi and Lonnie Love were in
attendance as well as many of twitch's
friends from So You Think You Can Dance
and The Ellen Degeneres Show he was
someone that was just beautiful and he
lived his life from Love and he made you
feel a certain way
Allison and twitch have two children
together six-year-old son Maddox and
three-year-old daughter ziya twitch is
also dad to Allison's 14 year old
daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people you know what I mean and Allison
said they will honor his legacy by
spreading light and happiness
my family and I have always said that we
wanted to make sure that our purpose was
lived out by bringing joy to people it's
gonna feel a little bit different
but we know that that's our purpose and
we'll still do that to this day
and I hope that we can remember
the feeling that he gave us and remember
that we can still move from there
[Music]